ich finde es hat alles hallo herzlich
willkommen manuel
ich bin heute nicht in meiner eigenen
küche denn ich bin heute in die pfalz
gefahren beim bus muss sieht man hier
mein sally guss ist doch richtig cool
morath als chauffeur und ich fahr mich
dazu oder mit mit ihnen her und zwar bin
ich jetzt hier und geht gleich die liebe
steffi besuchen wenn die steffi hat bei
mir bei dem gewinnspiel die kitchen in
maschine gewonnen und eigentlich will
ich sie per post geschickt aber ich habe
gast kommt das ist so langweilig fax
internet einfach ein gibt es ins nahm er
ein und vereinfachen und bringen sie ihr
einfach direkt persönlich und das machen
wir jetzt einfach fort mehr bitte ins
haus steht vor der haustür jetzt klingt
einfach nur weil eigentlich geht davon
aus dass der vorsprung kommt die
maschine schwer mit dem stück trage
vielleicht erkennt nämlich gar nichts
die post ist da
zimmer ausgedacht muslimische maschine
trage weil kommt darsteller musste kurz
ab das tier ein bisschen schüchtern
ich finde das perfekt
ich würde auch gern sein oder
ja ich habe auch zutaten dabei hat man
keine gleichen kuchen backen und im
backofen perfekt dann richten wir jetzt
alles hinten ich mache meine haare noch
mal zusammen die fall auseinander
und dann ziehen wir uns gleich wieder zu
früh als wohl weil
so schlecht ist alles normal
1000 zusammen mit sicherheit schlecht da
ist die anderen werden wir uns dann blut
abgenommen für die kommission alle unter
schock ein gerechtes ähnlich amberg hat
2000 kranke geschafft na ja so einfach
aber jetzt daheim und wo geht oder mit
ihr kommst du es geht also das ist also
ich komplan klavier können sie halt
schlecht schlecht irgendwo abgeben
niermann sondiert hat keine morgens
kommt für eine stunde im pflegedienst
paket wer wird alles gerichtet und könne
jetzt direkt anfangen
ich habe die zutaten ja dabei brauchst
du eine waage
das brauche ich nicht weil wir machen so
ein becher kuchen und zwar habe ich
einfach hier so ein becher schmand und
das benutzte man dann gleich praktisch
als mengenangabe es kommt immer ein
welcher dann von anderen praktisch ich
überlege welche kassen ist ja genau das
ist hier zum becher group und genau 200
gramm becher joghurt nehmen es wäre auch
möglich so dann würde ich sagen würde
dass ich mag so oft okay also dann zeigt
mir aber schließt design bahrain damit
benchmark und dann direkt wird gerd
löffelmann rausgekriegt ich wollte es
nicht mit gewalt weil dann habe ich
nämlich immer dann ja vier eier größe m
ja genau diese einfach zu die himmlische
sein
dem handrührgerät gehört und ich habe
manchmal sorgen gemacht haben jedes ei
zwei minuten rühren und irgendwann ist
dass man so größer ist oder wenn mit der
mama mal alleine fischer ich habe da
gibst du dir das an die sammler
er sagte mir mal dabei die clips die
zutaten reinschieben mit das darfst du
gleich machen
da können wir zwar schon mal den zug
gebracht
zucker ist es daneben als ein bett
geholt und das darfst du gleich rein
drücken okay ich habe dann irgendwann
immer meinen mann dazu geholt und hab
gesagt hat wie du weißt du dir
irgendwann wenn man dann zum
viertelstunde schon gerührt er berührt
und es wird immer mehr zeigen immer mehr
18 ist da rein schützen
danke dass man es einfach kurz verrühren
bis jetzt könnt ihr gerade noch so in
welcher mail becher kakao und becher
kokos auf messen oder darf da auch sein
mag von mir dazu geben möchtest du ich
mag seinen becher und teamarbeit
wie bist du eigentlich auf meinen kanal
gekommen und wann ich würde sagen von
drei vierteln jahre ungefähr war meine
schwester hat sich eine regenbogen torte
gewünscht für ihre tochter
und dann habe ich gegoogelt und youtube
videos anschauen und dann kam ich auf
deine
die torte und ich fand die halt total
genial mit der deko auf die schulter
schlagen aus
genau so eine bin ich mal machen aber
ich habe diese diese bremse diese presse
nicht genau
wir rühren klar ich habe noch zwei
sachen die wir da rein machen müssen
ich habe das damals gelassen mit dem mit
dem regenbogen kuchen weil einfach die
zeit gefehlt hat aber nicht beim 1 media
die gespeicherten ist und auch er was
ich dann einmal nach gemacht habe dieses
okinii welchen und ja ich auch schon
ganz oft nachgemacht auch immer mehr
viel kann ich glaube da immer noch eine
gemeinsamkeit mit dem knoblauch
knoblauch prüfen kann für mich in jedes
essen anfangen
definitiv also wenn die ganze menschheit
knoblauch essen wird ferner das sei
nicht so schlimm gekommen ist ganz toll
dass alles drängt gleichen backpulver
schulte nee das ist kommt das ganze pack
gmbh jetzt darfst du und ich muss noch
ein becher köhler aber glaube ich nichts
vergesse alles klasse ein bisschen
backpulver das mixed mannschaft kokos
auch andere
keine sauerei hier
wie alle 17 19 gewesen
es geht so große struktur arbeiten
ja aber nur zwei mal ein bisschen
abwechslung
ich hab' hab' ich wollte ins
fitnessstudio gehen weil die kleine kam
habe ich weiter und dann habe ich
überlegt ein schlichtes vernünftige
arbeiten zu gehen
finde ich die zeit nicht heraus und
zufällig ist parallel werden dich
probetraining termin hatte kam die die
anzeige gedacht bewerbe ich mich super
geklappt und jetzt arbeite ich zwei aber
für mich ist es halt einfach wichtig
gewesen ist die kinder nicht nicht
irgendwo abgeben
man kann abends gucken und nach den
kleinen geschlafen während porsche etwas
mit 2 also wirklich weil ich merke schon
mit der kamera also wie viel arbeit das
macht und ich komme morgens mit ihr
immer total schlecht dann trudelten
probier haben abschrecken und es
schmeckt nicht mehr auf das gesicht sagt
alles
eigentlich schon diese form direkten
butter margarine egal was ich habe also
ich selbst angefangen als ich mit ihm
schwanger war
ich erkläre ich halt nicht arbeiten
gegangen in den schlaf und irgendwie war
mir ein bisschen lang dann habe ich
meine erste funde an torten angefangen
hat es bei mir auch mein gedanke habe
ich zwar schon immer aber als die tamira
dann auf der welt habe und nicht weniger
an der uni war oder ich war ein fehler
auch an der uni und dann braucht es
andere sachen muss ich irgendwie
beschäftigen
so ungefähr 25 minuten es kommt auf die
backform for fun aber reichen
da warten wir jetzt einfach 25 minuten
mitmachen gleich die stäbchen problem
dieser an stocker oder holzstäbchen oder
fingerdruck egal wir räume hier kurz auf
und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder
dann hab ich mir dann kam eingefangen
und muss
wir haben das erste mal ist ein bisschen
kleiner
und sonst die haben fallen schickte man
bei der ärztin
es sind ja noch vier wochen zu klein war
sie denke ich dass das ernste bisweilen
es waren keine organischen filmbilder
systems alles ganz gut
es ist halt so klein ich muss beobachtet
werden haben früher junge reiter spritze
bekommen falls zu früh kommt und 33
noch haben es notkaiserschnitt kann man
eine limburger macht der gar nicht dabei
war total fertig also optischer
schrecklich man wieder dann abends kam
der als 16 stunden gedauert bis er
durfte meine kurse vom klassischen schon
immer hat gemerkt dass ich kommentiere
aufstehen wenn man nicht trügen
ist also hat sich durchgekämpft das ist
eine kämpferin deine chance und du hast
ja auch erst nach drei monaten gefühl
ganz tolle stammtische drei monaten zur
schwester auf
du kannst auch sprechen
am liebsten
dass amelie er liebt sie über alles
die gesundheit
sie hat auch härtsfelder machen aber die
die gleiche sich quasi selbst aus
ich hab halt mal was sagt das wichtigste
für mich oder für uns ist eigentlich
dass sie zu hause ist
wir sind öfter im krankenhaus gewesen
jetzt schon vergleich alt und das tut
dann hat schon von der familie getrennt
wissen zu hause selbst wenn die winter
ständig infekte charakter und leihen wir
haben auch sauerstoff an dem abend war
schockiert ich habe die ganze zeit immer
gedacht okay solange die man angreift
lassen sich nur weiterlaufen er immer
noch mit dem gedanken bis samstag ist ja
noch zeit
vielleicht gewinnt dennoch aber dann war
der satz weg und ja das habe ich ja ich
habe dieses gewinnspiel gemacht und die
regel war ja der die meisten likes und
das war halt bisschen
ein bisschen blöd die stecken hat in
einem bild eingestellt von der tochter
unsere text dazu geschrieben so ganz
neutral und sie hat die meisten likes
tickt also dort über 600 personen total
trat und den negativen kommentaren hieß
hat gelöscht habe aber gewusst dass die
gewonnen hat weil das konnte eigentlich
keine rolle
aber ich habe natürlich dann auch
kontonummern die gewinnspiele regeln
geändert und habe gesagt okay jetzt
aufgrund ihrer live eben die maschine
noch eine
ich habe zehn personen also ohne jetzt
stabil mit zu ziehen sie hat ja schon
jetzt habe ich die zehn personen
genommen also fünf aus facebook fünf aus
youtube mit den meisten leid denn ich
wollte einfach nicht dass eben auch leer
ausgehen weil ihr habt ja viel mühe
gegeben hin zugeschrieben gedichte
geschrieben geschichte ich dachte mir
das muss ich eben auch belohnt werden
gebt euch auch noch mal die chance und
ich habe 18 zu verlegen also fünf aus
facebook für haushalte und dann mal fünf
die meinen beitrag geteilt haben
praktisch 25 namen in dieser schüssel
und es wäre mein schön zusammen jetzt
stehen wieder alle chancen offen über
einem kleinen gelben schulbus genau
meine schuld bewusst und ich würde sagen
magst du mir einmal durch röhren und die
stimmzettel aus weil natürlich kann
keiner von uns
dann darf studie zu machen und einen
gibst du mir okay du bist ein zettel
gibt es mir keine er möchte nicht
optimal auf gucken wir mal was drin
steht und das system oder die glückliche
gewinnerin mal auf glatten nicht mehr
aufmachen und vorlesen und spannung
steigt er macht sehr spannend stefanie
anderer und sie hat den bikepark geteilt
auf facebook
aber stefan die durch den beitrag
geteilt auf facebook und du wirst die
glückliche gewinnerin der 2
auch himbeereis genau die gleiche genau
das was ich hoffe ein glückwunsch und
sorry an alle anderen arbeitsweise
eigentlich immer nur eine gehört dass
alle mitgemacht habt und die gedichte
und geschichten bett übrigen parteien
triebschnee mitinstalliert nein nicht
den apfel den zettel mit den normal darf
ich den haben
nein naja egal ist
ich weiß dass stefanie war also stefanie
du meldest dich bitte innerhalb von
einer woche bei mir per e mail an info
at this torten bild.de
dann kannst du ja direkt auch eine
adresse mit schicken und ich schicke dir
dann die kitchenaid so als hätte es
schon noch mal genau die gleiche die in
himbeereis und ich finde es ganz toll
wie viele hier bei dem gewinnspiel
mitgemacht haben
ich glaube es waren insgesamt über 2.000
kommentare schade natürlich noch dass
ich bei meinen üblichen videos nicht so
viel zu lachen habe und so viel zu lesen
habe weil die geschichten und die witze
die waren echt total super aber ich
finde es echt toll dass sie da alle
mitgemacht habt und die witze und die
geschichten werde ich euch alle noch
teilen und vorlesen und war echt viel
super waren echt viele gute kommunale
dabei mental fühle ich mich
richtig gut aus ja so schön nach herz
kuchen anschneiden der jetzt gar nicht
an
dann schneidet den später an für deinen
mann dann kriegt dann nämlich ein ganzes
herz setzte ihn trotzdem um keine mittel
ephedrin oder stürzen
ich habe mich gut gefühlt
wenn man sehe ja perfekt genau das ist
ein bisschen zu warm und dann könnt ihr
den später einfach zusammen essen
ich weiß wird er schmeckt weil der
morath hat mit denen er mal gemacht zu
meinem geburtstag also diese stadt
besser kuchen den murat unserem ihres zu
seinem geburtstag gemacht habe dass ich
zweiter schönere herzform aber meiner
man heute auch sauber von samira und
will murat naja ok bestätigen als total
viel spaß gemacht hier ja ich finde es
auch sehr schön
just gern noch mal kommen sie ja dann
recht bestimmt auf jeden fall wünsche
dir ganz viel spaß mit der kitchenaid
und die passt hier echt gut rein
räumlich überraschend konnte das habt
ihr wirklich also die ganze letzte woche
schon überraschungen und heute habt es
doch noch mal dann dürft ihr das rezept
aus teil ist blog nachlesen blog.de und
wir sehen uns ganz einfach beim nächsten
mal wieder wieder in meiner eigenen
küche
lasst euch schmecken dankeschön